According to Forbes – last time they published
their rich list – Amazon owner Jeff Bezos
was the richest man in the world, with a fortune
estimated at around 177 billion dollars.
That’s a number that’s quite hard to get
your head around, so let me put it this way:
Jeff Bezos’ personal fortune is larger than
the GDP of 75% of countries around the world.
That’s one man wielding the equivalent riches
of a nation, and a fairly big one at that.
This is a level of wealth nobody could conceivably
spend in a lifetime, no matter how expensive
their tastes.
Seriously - Jeff is 57 years of age at the
time of recording this video.
Now, he’s probably going to have his head
cryogenically frozen and live forever, but
for the sake of making a point, let’s assume
he’s going to live to 80.
In order to use up all of his 177 billion
dollars before he died (discounting interest),
he would need to spend almost 22 million dollars
every single day for the rest of his life.
That’s well over 10 times the average income
an American makes over their entire career,
every single day, for about 8400 days in a
row.
Yeeeeah.
But here’s something interesting.
While Jeff Bezos may well be the richest man
in modern times, he isn’t the richest human
being ever to have lived.
In fact, remarkably enough, if you adjust
for inflation, he isn’t even close.
The individual who holds that title is estimated
to have been in possession of a fortune well
over twice the size of poor old Jeff’s,
and larger than the fortunes of Elon Musk,
Mark Zuckerberg, Warren Buffet, and Jack Ma…
combined.
The funny thing is, despite his vaunted financial
position in the annals of human history, there’s
a very good chance you’ve never even heard
of this guy.
That being the case, let me introduce you:
This is Mansa Musa - the richest man in history.
As for why you haven’t heard of him, there
are two good reasons for that - first, he
was born almost 750 years ago.
And second, he was the sultan of the Mali
empire.
Most of my viewers live in Europe and the
US - two parts of the world whose school systems
have not traditionally put a lot of emphasis
on African history.
But that’s a shame, because the Mali empire
- the largest ever seen in Western Africa
- was really quite something.
At its height in the 14th century, it covered
almost half a million square miles and was
home to around 5% of the world’s population.
It rose incredibly quickly - in the space
of just a couple of generations during what’s
known as the golden age of trade in Africa.
The rise of the Mali empire was built on its
unfathomable wealth, and that came primarily
from two things: gold, and salt, both of which
were in rich local supply.
So much so that at the time, approximately
half of all the gold in the Old World - that’s
Europe, Africa, and Asia - came from just
3 goldmines in Mali.
The idea that a vast fortune could come from
gold is no surprise, but the fact salt was
such a major factor might seem a little odd
when viewed through our modern lens.
But in many parts of fourteenth century Africa,
salt was an incredibly valuable commodity
- to the right buyer, it was literally worth
its weight in gold.
As unlikely as that may sound, it actually
makes a lot of sense when you think about
it.
After all, salt is an essential part of the
human diet - we quite literally can’t survive
without it.
It also happens to make bland food much more
palatable, and can be used as a preservative,
which was especially useful before the invention
of reliable refrigeration.
In regions where salt was sparse, it was priceless.
Gold, on the other hand, is… shiny.
We use it in all sorts of things today - from
electronics to spaceships - but the fact it
looked kinda pretty was about the extent of
its appeal in the 14th century.
Mansa Musa was born sometime around 1280 AD,
and he came to the throne as the 10th ruler
of the Mali empire in approximately 1312 AD.
His rise to power was a slightly odd one - he
was only ever supposed to be a temporary ruler,
selected for this caretaker position when
his predecessor, Abubakari Keita II, decided
to go and find out what was on the other side
of the Atlantic Ocean.
As you do.
The emperor took some 3000 ships and set off
into the vast expanse of ocean, leaving behind
his throne and one of the greatest fortunes
in history, all without a shred of evidence
that there was anything to actually discover
on the other side.
So far as we know, neither Abubakari Keita
II nor his 3000-strong fleet was never seen
again, though a few historians believe he
did indeed make it all the way to South America…
but that’s a story for another day.
The important bit for our purposes is that
this one-time ruler of the Mali empire never
came back from his bold voyage, and so Mansa
Musa officially ascended to the throne, where
he set about extending the borders of his
lands and growing his already vast wealth.
By the way, I should point out that ‘Mansa’
is a job title rather than a first name - it
means ‘emperor’ or ‘sultan’.
Anyway, as the head of one of Africa’s greatest
empires, just how rich was Mansa Musa?
Well before we get to the numbers, how about
an example.
The new emperor was a devout Muslim, meaning
much like today, it was his solemn duty to
undertake the Hajj at least once in his lifetime
(the Hajj being a pilgrimage to Mecca and
one of the 5 pillars of Islam).
It’s no exaggeration to say that, when Mansa
Musa decided it was time to go to Mecca, the
pilgrimage that ensued from Mali to the Arabian
peninsula is one of the most remarkable journeys
ever made by a human being.
Well, I say ‘a’ human being.
What I actually mean is, 60,000 men and women,
100 elephants, 80 camels, a personal guard
of 500 highly trained warriors, and enough
food, water, and animals to eat for everyone.
Basically, Mansa Musa undertook this 2700
miles pilgrimage at the centre of an entire
movable city - a caravan that stretched longer
than the eye could see.
I mean, it was bigger and more extravagant
even than the entourage Aladdin took with
him to impress Princess Jasmine, and that
was made by a magic genie.
Now, if you’re anything like me you’ll
like to take a bit of spending money when
you go on a trip, and it seems Mansa Musa
did too, because tucked away in a bum bag
- I absolutely refuse to say fanny pack - he’d
reserved a little extra cash to treat himself
along the way.
Of course, ‘a little extra cash’ has something
of a different meaning when you’re the richest
man ever - in this case, it was 21,000 kilograms
of solid gold.
You know, just in case there were some bargains
to be had in duty free.
You might be wondering how exactly he transported
such a vast amount of gold – or at least,
the twenty thousand nine hundred and ninety-nine
kilograms that didn’t fit in his bum bag.
That job was left to his 12,000 slaves, each
of whom was given almost 2 kilos in solid
gold apiece.
Along with the bullion, Mansa Musa also brought
thousands of kilos of gold dust, which was
used as currency throughout his kingdom.
Take all this together - the tens of thousands
of people and hundreds of animals, the unimaginable
quantities of gold - and it’s fair to say
the world had never before seen anything quite
like the display of wealth Mansa Musa put
on during his trip to Mecca.
And yet, in reality, this extravagant show
of riches wasn’t all that it seemed.
As you may well know, another of the pillars
of Islam is Zakat - which is the giving alms
to charitable causes.
That’s right, Mansa Musa hadn’t brought
all this gold for himself - he was planning
to give it away.
Like, all of it.
It’s said that so much gold was handed out
to the poor en-route to Mecca that Mansa Musa
singlehandedly crashed the price of the commodity
across most of North Africa and the western
Arabian peninsula, including in major gold-trading
cities like Cairo, Medina, and Mecca itself,
precipitating a decade long recession.
He was basically the Mr. Beast of his day.
But his generosity was about more than just
cold hard gold dust.
Mansa Musa also wanted to share his beliefs
far and wide.
But being the richest man in history, he didn’t
settle for simply spreading the word.
Instead, he started a tradition - every Friday
for the entirety of the pilgrimage, no matter
where he found himself, he had a mosque built.
Considering the trip took almost 2 years in
total, that’s a lot of mosques.
In the interests of presenting a balanced
view, I should point out that a lot of time
has passed since Mansa Musa ruled over the
Mali empire, and written records from the
time are pretty much non-existent.
That means it’s difficult to be completely
sure his intentions on this pilgrimage were
solely philanthropic and spiritual.
Some historians suspect he was keen to show
off his immense wealth and resources as a
kind of medieval PR exercise - a branding
mission designed to impress his friends, frighten
his enemies, and just generally put the Mali
empire on the map.
And it certainly did exactly that - both figuratively
and literally.
Because as a direct result of the fame Mansa
Musa gained for himself and his empire on
his way to Mecca, both would soon begin to
crop up on world maps for the first time,
including the Catalan Atlas - one of the most
important medieval maps of the 14th century.
You can see Mansa Musa himself right here,
holding a gold coin and just generally looking
like a bit of a boss.
The pilgrimage also acted like a sort of epic
recruitment campaign, with Mansa Musa’s
wealth, generosity, and effortless power winning
him thousands of supporters and securing his
empire the services of some of the most celebrated
thinkers and artists of the era - many of
whom he brought back west when the caravan
returned home after completing the Hajj.
Speaking of returning home, it was around
this time that Mansa Musa began to sprinkle
a little gold dust within the borders of his
own lands, too, building mosques and madrasas
- those are educational institutions - in
many cities.
But there was one place in particular for
which Mansa Musa reserved most of his attention
- Timbuktu.
It’s somewhere you’ve almost certainly
heard of, even if you don’t know why and
can’t point to it on a map.
You may even think it’s some kind of mythical
location like Atlantis or El Dorado - don’t
worry, plenty if people do.
These days, Timbuktu is used in the English
language as a byword for somewhere unimaginably
distant and remote, a status it likely earned
because no European managed to figure out
how to get there until the 1830s.
But the main reason the name became famous
in the first place is largely thanks to Mansa
Musa.
He annexed Timbuktu on his way back from Mecca
and set about turning it into one of the most
important centres for trade, culture, religion,
and learning not just in Africa, but around
the world.
The Djinguereber Mosque, which Mansa Musa
paid for with 200 kilograms of solid gold,
still stands today and makes up part of Timbuktu
University, for a time one of the world’s
premiere seats of knowledge boasting 25,000
students and a library of a million books
– that’s more than were held in the Great
Library of Alexandria at the height of its
flame - I mean fame.
And all this at a time when most Europeans
believed Africa was a continent full of uncultured
savages.
Putting an exact number on Mansa Musa’s
bank account today is obviously pretty difficult,
but the figure most often cited - accounting
for inflation - is approximately 400 billion
dollars – that’s about the GDP of Norway
or Ireland.
In truth, it’s nothing more than a finger
in the air - not that it really matters.
Mansa Musa was a man so wealthy that the exact
numbers involved aren’t important.
His wealth was, to all intents and purposes,
limitless.
He could do whatever he wanted, whenever he
felt like it.
Luckily, it seems that what he most often
wanted to do was give his wealth away in order
to improve the lives of others.
And there are worse ways to spend the greatest
fortune in history, I’m sure you’ll agree.
Thanks for watching.